why don't we go
next
to
you know we tried last time and it
didn't work let's go to eric from cancun
mexico eric are you with us this time
david hello yes
i'm great pleasure to talk to you i've
been trying for months and weeks
here's the thing i'm thinking um
my family wants to get a passport to us
and i'd like to visit the states blog
i've been seeing your videos and from
feral cousins and young turks and i've
seen very deranged individuals both
civilians and in the police and army
the thing is
it's safe for tourists and foreigners to
go there with all the wackos and
psychopaths around
i mean listen everybody needs to do
their own risk assessment but
statistically speaking statistically
speaking
the us is not an unsafe place to be you
know there are safer and less safe
places in the u.s the big country
um in the big cities you have to take
the normal precautions that you take in
any big city
um but you need to make that assessment
i mean the u.s is not an unsafe place to
go to statistically but that doesn't
mean bad things don't happen bad things
happen all the time you really have to
make that call
yeah i'm
i'm really with the mindset that i like
in the song of
alpha bill of forever young hoping for
the best but expect the words like what
happened in that mall in el paso and
other thing i've been a martial artist
since 8 years old would it be illegal
for me to defend myself or would i be
charged with assault if i fight back
uh i think you would be perfectly within
your legal rights to defend yourself
regardless of your martial arts training
yeah i've been in taekwondo in krav maga
in capoeira a bit of jujitsu and karate
yeah
um it's been a pleasure and one quick
thing
do you remember when republicans were
mad at dr seuss
yes and you know he's not even a real
doctor he's not a medical doctor
um i think they would be angry because
they made books about trump's other
relatives for example he is left-leaning
uncle delorax he is
more naughty but logical's half-sister
the sour kangaroo and he is more
handsome and more wholesome causing the
grinch
what do you think very nice very nice
eric i i love it um how how is cancun
which part of cancun do you live in the
downtown or where
and in the heart of downtown
it's very nice it's
it's like um sauna old year but in
winter
it's climatizing
beautiful all right
eric thank you so much for the call we
love our mexican viewers
thank you all right there is eric
eric from cancun what a call folks what
a call maybe my new favorite caller i
have to tell you